the One Piece manga just dropped an
absolute Banger because for the very
first time ever we saw the full devil
fruit transformation of one of the
legendary five gorosei and let me just
tell you that this was shocking in more
ways than just one because not only does
Saint Saturn here appear to be some sort
of demon Bull from Japanese mythology
but we also saw some truly mind-blowing
magical demonic abilities that honestly
I in some parts at least have no logical
explanation for but it doesn't really
mean that we won't be trying to dig deep
deep into speculation later on but
that's not all that this chapter
revealed of course because it also
appears that Bonnie and Saint Saturn
have major beef to saddle because when
she came face to face with him she lost
her mind and straight up stabbed the
gorosei in the chest like damn girl
Bonnie here is not messing around and
she also would be a cool addition to the
crew but on top of all that Luffy and
kizaru of course also continued their
epic brawl with Luffy even busting out
some new gear 5 techniques that we
haven't seen before but even that is
still not enough to bring down kizaru
because the Admiral got away from Luffy
once again and nearly wiped out the main
Stella Vega pump and honestly I'm
starting to uh sweat a little bit about
how this is actually all going to go
because when Luffy now ran out of time
for year 5 at the end of this chapter
that now really puts the straw hats and
the rest of his allies in a truly
terrible situation with Saint Saturn and
kizaru still ready to fight this could
turn out way worse than we ever thought
possible and speaking of the always
chill Admiral though I mean I don't have
to tell you but man like even here again
kizeru is just one of the most stylish
characters in the entire story the suit
the golden glass is the entire Mafia
style that he always has going I mean if
you're like me you'd probably wish that
you could have a piece of that drip cake
right here but luckily today's sponsor
holds current will make the stream come
true for both me and you now you
probably know about holzkern's products
because I wear them in pretty much all
of my videos you might have seen me wear
my beautiful watch and you definitely
know this really insane necklace like I
love this so much that I just wear like
always and I really think it speaks for
the quality of a sponsor when you
actually love to use their items on a
daily basis and not only are they
insanely stylish horse current's entire
Concepts also revolves around helping
the environment using a lot of beautiful
natural stone and wood in their products
which in a really nice way makes you
feel a little bit closer and connected
to Nature I think their watches are just
insanely beautifully crafted but they
also have accessories like Rings
bracelets earrings and maybe most
importantly sunglasses so you can
actually get some of kizero's drip
Yourself by getting your own pair using
my code Ohara 15 for 15 off with the
link in the description below shipping
is free worldwide and almost as fast as
kizodu with two to five day to the US
and most of the EU before we get to
anything else we of course do have to
talk about Saint Saturn and the chaos
that we witnessed in this chapter
because if I'm being completely honest
I'm still trying to really wrap my head
fully around what we just saw here but I
will try my best to explain everything
that we know for a fact and can at least
guess or assume about Saint Saturn's
abilities and first of all we of course
have this incredible magical demonic
circle with a five-pointed star suddenly
appearing in the middle of the island
and then right after this saint Saturn
makes his first moves on the islands now
before we get to the man himself here
man I guess yeah we have to discuss this
diagram because of the massive clues
that it might give us about Saturn and
even the other godosei as well now first
off we don't actually know if Saturn
himself created this magic circle or if
the circle was somehow necessary for
Saturn to make his transformation which
we'll discuss in full detail in just a
moment I mean the east thing to say here
is that Saturn's Powers made the circle
appear but I also wonder if maybe
someone like the world secret ruler emu
actually created the circle that then
allowed Saturn to transform really it
isn't that wildly impossible since back
in chapter 1085 when we first saw the
Silhouettes of the godosei
transformation as well emo was also
present there and using their mysterious
Powers before the godosei actually
transforms however just as important as
who made the circle is what it can tell
us about Saturn's Powers now this circle
and the five-pointed star symbol is
called a pentagram or Pentacle and let
me tell you it is a massive Rabbit Hole
of religious and cultic symbolism like
which I already Dove head first into so
that you don't have to you're welcome by
the way but interestingly enough this
symbol has many different meanings
across different cultures that you might
not even be aware of of course recent
pop culture has basically Associated an
upside down five-pointed star with
things like devil worship and the Occult
but if you go further back in history
there's actually a lot more to discover
about this sacred symbol for example in
some religious or historical systems the
fight pointed star actually represents
harmony with nature in the universe as
part of sacred geometry and it was even
used in the Christian church to
represent good deeds and charity but
maybe the most interesting connection
and the one that makes the most sense
for one piece is the star's association
with five uh let's call it the five
elements those being of course earth air
water spirits and fire now why is this
important well for one this magic circle
and star appeared alongside with an
explosion of black fire which all
connectors and Saturn more specifically
in just a moment but first before we
even get to see the transformed World
Noble in the first place we get this
super creepy warning that anyone below
the rank of rear Admiral is absolutely
forbidden from looking at Saint Saturn
and his transformation and honestly when
I first read this I was kind of thinking
what this is like this super unnecessary
over-the-top kind of like ah I'm a world
Noble unnecessarily specific command so
surely if someone looked they would
maybe just get demoted or something
right but no we got this instead like
this poor dude just looked at the man
and his head literally exploded like
what like my jaw still dropping I feel I
mean if I can be honest this kind of
felt like some sort of like cursed
energy technique from something like
Jutsu kaisen not a devil fruit power
from One Piece seriously though this
just brings up a ton of questions here
like was this truly an unbreakable spell
caused by the magic circle or was it
some sort of power that saying Saturn
can use based on the commands that he
gives and what about the straw hats and
their allies will they be affected by
those rules because you might be able to
argue that someone like usop or Nami is
maybe weaker than a rear Admiral every
man please Oda don't do anything like
that to me but it also makes me wonder
why this specifically rare Admirals and
above that aren't affected is it because
they have some Mastery of hockey there
or is there some other specific reason
like I don't know man for now that's
enough about evil curses and magical
diagrams let's get straight to the man
himself and wow I was really shocked
when I saw his full giant form here and
that's because when we first saw the
Silhouettes in chapter 1085 he had horn
soap I originally thought he might have
some sort of minotaurus-like mythical
Zone fruit but clearly not instead his
appearance is very similar to the
Japanese Yokai called usioni which
literally is just a demon cow or demon
bull so what do we know about these
types of mythical creatures well for one
they're super creepy with their
spider-like lower bodies and bull horns
kind of reminds me of black Maria from
kairo's crew actually but other than
that there's honestly not that much that
we kind of know about these creatures
Japanese mythology states that they were
incredibly vicious and would attack and
eat humans any time that they could and
what well they don't appear to have any
specific special abilities they usually
live near water and would even sometimes
work with other Yokai like the serpent
women in order to capture more prey
slash humans and strangely enough that
seems to be about it that we get from
mythology but there's actually one other
super important detail that we must
absolutely discuss here so let's
actually jump back to the actual view
that we get of Saturn here because he
also has this mysterious flame-shaped
pattern on his lower spider body which
brings us back to the five Elemental
abilities that we mentioned earlier that
might be connected to the five Elder
stars and the five-pointed star right
here because like we said the star
appeared with a burst of fire so it does
make me wonder if Saturn can also use
fire-based abilities alongside his
spider bull transformation which
honestly would also make sense with the
Marines head exploding earlier because
out of all those five elements fire
would seem to be the most likely to
cause that type of damage and so so wow
I mean on top of already having kizaru
and his light abilities the straw hats
may now also be dealing with a rampaging
fire using spider ball like I definitely
would not want to be on that island
right now but on top of potential
Firepower Saint Saturn has clearly also
awakened his Zone devil fruit if it is a
devil fruit maybe it's just a literal
devil I mean that might be a possibility
but it's at least hinted at by the cloud
scarf that we now know very well because
this is the same indicator for awakened
zones that we've already seen with
Luffy's gear 5 as well as with the two
secret agents from earlier in the arc
and now Beyond his powers the magical
star also appeared with the number five
which makes me wonder if there is a
ranking or order system to the godosei
themselves and if that's the case then
it makes sense for Saturn to be the
fifth in ranking but does that mean that
he is the weakest or the most powerful
like I mean who knows at this point I'm
really just trying to figure out what
happened to that poor dude's head and
I'd say that this is honestly maybe the
very first time that I'm actually
feeling actual legit danger for the
straw I had crew in a very very long
time reminding me back of when things
went super sideways on Sava ODI and also
one more thing about the five-pointed
star and the five elements like if you
remember my chapter review way back of
when we first got to see Saint Saturn
and what his name was and all the names
of the other Guru say you will know that
all of their like different planets that
they refer to also correspond one to one
to elements but yeah I mean this is just
some super weird stuff happening right
now but what's not weird is you
subscribing to the channel for even more
one-piece content just like this however
all that weirdness and danger clearly
didn't stop Bonnie from just straight up
stabbing Saint Saturn in the chest at
the end of this chapter because of some
sort of triggered memory that she had
about her father's transformation into a
cyborg and so clearly there seems to
have been some major conflict Brewing
between these two but this scene also
clearly shows us that he can actually be
damaged although honestly I wouldn't be
surprised at all if he just brushes off
this attack like it was nothing and then
heals the damage in the very next
chapter we'll see now you might be
thinking that's all that we learned
about the godosei from this chapter but
actually let's take all of this that we
learned about Saturn and try to apply it
to the rest of the gurosei because if
we're sticking with this theme of five
elements which of course could be wrong
but it does seem like a fairly decent
Theory at this point at least then what
abilities might the other four have well
just going off the clearest images that
we got from chapter 1085 we have some
sort of idea what the other Zone
Transformations could look like and when
we compared to how they were standing
earlier in that chapter we can say that
same Mercury on the far right looks like
some sort of animal with a large Tusk or
horn which could be an elephant or Rhino
type transformation and to me that fits
pretty well with an earth type ability
but to be fair Saturn in Japanese has
the kanji for Earth so maybe he is the
earth guy we'll find out right next to
him is Saint Mars who looks like some
some sort of bird which goes pretty
perfectly with air powers and looking
around we have the most human looking
transformation which is Saint Nazo Judo
and honestly I'm not too sure if he
could represent water or Spirit here and
the same could be said for San Jupiter
who just looks like a blob with a large
open mouth so not exactly clear about
those two but maybe the most
disappointing part about all of this is
that we still can't clearly pinpoint
down exactly what their actual devil
fruit Transformations will be like like
their full transformation I mean we
already thought that they would probably
be some sort of mythical zones and now
we know that they might all be based on
Japanese mythology but which ones
exactly well still a little bit too hard
to guess for now I think but with this
very first hint of the godosei's
mind-bending powers and possible
connection to Demons themselves or
Devils I guess like transcending devil
fruits themselves we finally know how
the world government might have stayed
in power for centuries which honestly
with all these different factions
Marines the no the reverie and
everything the guru say Kong I mean yeah
if you want a complete explanation and
breakdown of the entire world government
system as well as all and I do mean all
of the incredible military forces that
they command you can watch that video
right here thanks for watching